In Indonesia, emergency officials have raised the alert level...
...of the erupting Anak Krakatau volcano that triggered a deadly tsunami.
The wave killed at least 430 people on the western coast last week.
In Madagascar, former President Andry Rajoelina is set to return to power...
...after winning the country's presidential runoff vote,...
...according to results released Thursday.
Police in the eastern Democratic Republic of Congo...
...fired live ammunition and tear gas Thursday to break up protesters...
...who are angry about a decision to exclude them from Sunday's presidential election.
In Bangladesh, the opposition BNP...
...and its Islamist ally Jamaat-e-Islami say more than 11,500 of their followers...
...have been arrested ahead of Sunday's national election.
Finally from Greece,...
...a bomb exploded outside a church in the center of Athens on Thursday morning,...
...injuring a policeman and a church employee.